ah bon soir marine calme et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation tardive
1 sur rt france alors on l'a dit elle et
à l'avenir d'être condamné à prendre
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
compenser l excès d'émissions de co2
entre 2015 et 2018 concrètement comment
l'état peut-il à réparer ce dommage
est bien c'est justement ce qui va
devoir être mis en place c'est difficile
à dire encore justement est ce que
l'état va commencer par des mesures dans
les transports dans l'habitation dans le
logement en fait le juge ne lui impose
rien il ne fait que rappeler finalement
cette carence de l'état et comme dans la
sphère grande synthe en juillet dernier
et lui impose de prendre comme vous
l'avez dit toutes les mesures utiles
mais il ne se met pas à la place du
ministre des ministères et ne peut pas
donc bien gouverner à la place de ce
gouvernement il faut qu'il fasse le
travail est-ce que vous avez justement
l'espoir que ce jugement aboutisse et un
meilleur respect des engagements de
l'état en termes de pollution
alors en tout cas c'est un signal fort
puisqu'il s'agit donc pour la deuxième
fois d'une décision de justice qui vient
confirmer que l'état bien l'obligation
de respecter les engagements de la
cambre de paris en revanche ce qui est
un peu décevant c'est que le juge
considère donc que l'éthane la
responsabilité de compenser que 15
millions de tonnes équivalent co2 au
lieu des 62 millions de tonnes
équivalent co2 qu'il avait constaté
comme étant manquant sur le budget
précédent et malheureusement donc il ya
quelque chose qui manque parce qu'en
fait on ne peut pas juste compenser des
émissions carbone le retard que nous
prenons dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique elle n'a pas
que des pactes en matière d'émissions de
co2 c'est aussi une destruction de la
biodiversité une érosion des sols une
disparition des ressources en eau et ça
malheureusement ce n'est pas dit dans
cette décision de justice alors si je
vous comprends bien c'est une
demi victoire puisque la justice aurait
pu aurait dû peut-être allait même plus
loin dans sa dans sa sévérité
je pense qu'elle aurait dû aller plus
loin parce que les impacts du climat
aujourd'hui on sait ce n'est pas
seulement voilà du carbone dans
l'atmosphère c'est une réaction en
chaîne sur l'ensemble des mécanismes du
vivant et puis en plus les associations
demandaient une astreinte pour être sûr
que l'état est bien l'obligation d'agir
dont qu'elle réclame n'est 78 millions
d'euros d'astreinte et elles ne l'ont
pas obtenue alors que dans la décision
justement sur la pollution de l'air
encore une décision en carence fautive
obtenus par les amis de la terre il ya
quelques mois là l'état avait été
condamné à dix millions d'astreinte par
semestre
pour les actions qui n'ont pas donc été
mis en place
donc oui c'est une décision qui aurait
pu être plus ferme mais bon on peut déjà
dire qu'on est satisfait et que c'est un
bon signal je sais que ça peut paraître
un peu compliqué mais comment encourager
maintenant davantage l'état à respecter
ses engagements
alors là je vais peut-être paraître un
peu polémique nettement je ne fais
absolument pas confiance à ce
gouvernement pour respecter ses
engagements en matière climatique
personnellement je pense qu'on a vu
pendant ce quinquennat que ce n'était
pas la peine de leur faire confiance la
loi climat a été un échec c'est à dire
que même le haut conseil pour le climat
nous a fait savoir que avec les
engagements de la loi climat on ne
tenait absolument pas nos engagements le
climatique c'est-à-dire réduire a minima
si on veut s'en tenir aux accords de
paris à 50% vos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre d'ici 2030 tous les
scientifiques le disent la france n'y
est pas il faut renforcer ses mesures et
on le voit bien les mesurettes de ce
gouvernement ne sont absolument pas à la
hauteur d'eau cote malheureusement je
crois qu'il faut surtout changer de
gouvernement maintenant et est ce que
justement se respecte ses engagements
est ce qu'il dépend seulement
des états ne veulent pas forcément
seulement de la france mais des états de
manière générale
alors on le sait aujourd'hui la partie
repose sur les individus étaient en fait
extrêmement faibles passent à la marge
de manoeuvre dont il revient à qui
revient en fait
aux états et aux entreprises donc sans
l'état et sans la volonté des
entreprises malheureusement on
n'attendra pas de nos ambitions et donc
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment des signes
extrêmement clair au niveau du
législateur au niveau de la loi et c'est
ce à quoi devait répondre la loi climat
le compte n'y est pas très clairement et
donc heureusement que les élections
législatives arrivent parce qu'on a
besoin de nous re députés pour vraiment
changer la donne alors on va changer un
petit peu de sujets puisque une ong
autrichienne a déposé plainte 1 mardi à
la cour pénale internationale pour
crimes contre l'humanité contre le
président brésilien âgé à bolton à eau
pour son rôle dans la déforestation
amazonienne amazonienne pardon le droit
pénal international peut-il avoir plus
d'impact que le droit public national
je pense que c'est un tout il faut pas
tout miser non plus sur les outils
internationaux en revanche c'est clair
qu'au niveau international il nous faut
une cour pénale internationale qui soit
plus forte puisque là en l'occurrence
cette association elle a déposé une
plainte pour génocide pour crimes contre
l'humanité
or aujourd'hui justement en tant que
juriste nous plaidons avec par exemple
la fondation stop écocide pour la
reconnaissance dans le droit
international du crime des gosses id
pour pouvoir poursuivre également
l'ensemble de ces crimes
environnementaux que ce soit la
destruction des forêts au brésil la
pollution des fleuves par les industries
pétrolières au niger et tous ces crimes
qui met en danger l'habitabilité de
notre planète et donc très clairement si
tu es un bon signal on puisse aussi se
servir des outils internationaux au
pouvoir contraindre des états dans
lesquels une législation qui sont trop
faibles pour faire face à des
gouvernements qui ne veulent pas agir et
la france a évidemment du souci à se
faire merci coumarine calme et d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes présidente de
l'association wad légal merci encore une
fois d'avoir accepté notre invitation
tardive